danke danke
wenn ihr das auch mein hemd nennt man
schwerlich ziel ist herzlich willkommen
bayern ein video und zwar haben
christian und ich uns heute dazu
überreden lassen
die übrige moniert und schminken zu
lassen
von den beiden hatten was ich sagen
wollte das ist ein spiel auf der linken
seite weiß gar nicht wie ich bin pirat
und ich bin auf jeden fall werden wir so
ein bisschen geschenkt ich werde das
ganze bisschen vorspulen also so damit
es schneller geht und dann werden wir so
ein bisschen über das endresultat
diskutieren ich habe
wenn ihr das auf mich zu sehr gut
naja aber nicht auch mal schnell macht
macht halt nicht aber einig macht man
den hals das habe ich gelernt ich war
james stoppen in der jury
macht euch über meine augen es gar nicht
auf die augen nicht auf die augen aber
danach hat irgendwann reicht's auch
damit die macht alles meine nase in die
augen als ich das letzte mal geschehen
vor den ball schön macht mir nicht so
viel ich will das auch noch in die welt
hab ich endlich meine hand sind auch mal
kurz
ich habe das gefühl damals ganze in
meinen pulli guckt mich jetzt an deiner
augen zu
wieso also
jetzt kenne ich mein glaube ich ich hab
euch gesagt ich wollte das nicht
was hast du das kenne ich ja kein
problem ich bin schwer verschnitt wobei
alles auf verschließen
wer sich besseres wer sie können ja
meine kommentare schreiben wir besser
aussieht denn wenn ich dann alex wenn er
dann wirst du dich mal das jedenfalls
nicht noch neuen airline christian warum
das alles
junge leute im kopf jetzt bitte gar
nicht auf meine haare ich war grad
schnell duschen ich wollte nur eben ganz
schön doch was sagen also wenn sie
wegfallen ist auf jeden fall daumen nach
oben da und in der video beschreibung
findet ihr meinen you know how link es
gibt jetzt ab und zu mal so livestreams
so abends einfach wenn ich bock habt ich
werde das nicht groß posten einfach
online gehen fertig dann mal gucken was
da abgeht deswegen folgte auf jeden fall
war hammergeil und wie oft er hier oben
geht es halt so weiter mit meinem
letzten video da war christian glaub ich
dabei bei frontex parodie war das zeigt
dass auf jeden fall ab würd mich freuen
wir sehen uns nichts motor wiederholt